russia claims it has captured the
luhansk region in ukraine's east
it is also stepping up attacks against
civilian centers like residential
buildings and shopping malls ukraine's
civilian casualties and troop losses are
mounting as well is ukraine losing this
war not at all that's from my guest this
week joining me from lugano in
switzerland cat walker is a former u.s
ambassador to nato and a former u.s
special representative for ukraine
negotiations and he believes the west
should be doing more to support ukraine
remember the ukrainians are paying for
our security with their lives
we would be paying for their security
with higher prices but could cracks in
the western alliance derail long-term
support for ukraine
all this and more on conflict zone
[Music]
ambassador kurt volker welcome to
conflict zone
thank you very much great to be here
nato held a summit uh last week in which
it declared its strategic concept and
russia was labeled a direct threat to
the bloc how does that help ukraine
uh well i think first off
it's important that nato actually do his
first job which is collective defense
and so by recognizing the threat that
russia presents in europe as a whole not
only against ukraine but against nato
allies as well
nato's taking an important step and this
gives nato a foundation for improving
its own defense capabilities
increasing defense spending increasing
high readiness forces uh deploying
forces further forward all of this is
meant to contain russia it doesn't do
anything for ukraine specifically uh but
some of the other nato allies of course
including the united states and germany
and the uk are providing direct
assistance to ukraine but that's done
outside the nato framework now you've
said in a recent interview that when it
comes to protecting the bloc nato has
done a very good job you just said the
same thing right now but when it comes
to being relevant and effective in
crisis management during the biggest war
in europe quote nato hasn't
distinguished itself
is nato failing ukraine ambassador
volker
well i think nato is not playing a role
right now in this largest war in europe
nato was founded in order to create
security for the allies and it is doing
that
but its second core function from the
strategic concept even the one that was
just agreed
at the madrid summit it says the second
core function of nato is crisis
management and nato is not really
involved in ending this crisis
russia's war against ukraine
one thing that i think nato could be
doing even today
is providing a clearinghouse function
for arms shipments to ukraine the united
states is doing this out of ramstein air
base doing it on a bilateral basis with
many other countries but this is
something that nato has done before and
could do in this case as well what else
should nato be doing is it just about a
clearinghouse function or is there more
that nato could be doing to directly
help ukraine
yeah i think there are also functions in
terms of intelligence collection and
sharing with ukrainians there are
communications functions that could be
done uh and most importantly i think
it's the training and equipping of
ukrainian forces nato could do that but
it's being done only by individual
allies at this time so just going back
to that summit in madrid nato has
committed more troops to the east it has
committed more troops to the baltics it
has increased its uh
response force by a factor of eight to
about three hundred thousand nato is
still not on the right track
well no i think nato is on the right
track in terms of collective defense uh
as i said i think there it has done a
very good job uh the increases in high
readiness forces if they are truly
realized
will be very significant the forward
deployment of forces to poland romania
the baltic states that's very important
and the inclusion of finland and sweden
will do a lot to strengthen security in
northern europe so all of those things
are very positive uh it is again coming
to this question of ukraine and the
ongoing war in europe where
tens of thousands of people have been
killed and millions have been displaced
this is where we we need all of us
whether it's individual allies or nato
or frankly the european union or others
we need to step up our support for
ukraine so that ukraine can win this war
quickly let's talk about winning this
war quickly ukrainian president zilensky
has been asking for long-range artillery
pieces for months he's also asked for
five billion dollars per month to keep
the war going against russia is he
finally going to get this
uh he's getting some of what he's asking
for but not all of it
the u.s hiram's
missile launcher systems
have arrived in ukraine and are
beginning to be integrated into the
forces and that has already helped the
ukrainians take out some russian
ammunition depots for instance at
malitopol airport
so that is important they're also going
to be getting some more sophisticated
air defense systems which should help
protect cities against some of them but
i think the point that president
zielenski is making that he's not
getting them fast enough when he needs
them is he is that going to start to
happen now
uh unfortunately i don't see any change
in that uh i agree with president
zielinski uh he's not getting as much as
he needs he needs
hundreds of thousands of more rounds of
ammunition uh he needs you know dozens
more multiple launch rocket systems
artillery systems and uh he's getting
smaller numbers and he's getting them at
a slower pace than i think all of us
would like to see why is that happening
is that because nato is dragging its
feet or because these stocks just don't
exist to be able to provide them to
ukraine when ukraine wants them
well again this is not something that
nato is doing at all
it is something that individual nato
countries or particularly the united
states
germany i know has very low stocks
other nato countries also have very low
stocks the u.s has been drawing down its
stocks of defense materials and
providing it to ukraine
but is nonetheless taking a long time
this question for example about
providing these multiple launch rocket
systems
there are the our longer range artillery
we knew back in february and march that
this would be needed and it is now july
and they're just arriving so this is
something where we could have acted much
faster what is the risk if these weapons
aren't delivered to ukraine when they
want them
well the risk is that more ukrainians
die
the russians are using artillery
to pound ukrainian positions
they have longer-range artillery so when
they fire ukrainians don't have the
range to fire back they have thousands
and thousands and thousands more rounds
of ammunition
than the ukrainians have so the ratio is
almost tenfold what the russians are
delivering now the russian stocks are
inaccurate some of them don't work
estimates be anywhere from a half to
two-thirds don't work when they land but
even then this is very dangerous for
ukrainians if they get the systems there
they can push the russians back i'd like
to talk more about that and how the war
is going now the u.n has so far recorded
some
more than 10 000 civilian casualties in
ukraine some 12 million people have been
forced to flee their home and now over
the weekend russia is claiming that it
controls the luhansk region
is ukraine losing this war
not at all um russia entered this war in
order to rebuild the russian empire to
exterminate ukraine as a country and as
a civilization as a people and it has
utterly failed to do that the ukrainians
have pushed them back from kiev from the
north from
from sunni from china
from odessa so the ukrainians have
established that they will remain a
sovereign independent european democracy
this is critically important russia has
taken about 20 percent of ukrainian
territory uh that has come at a
tremendously high price for russia
they're going probably now not to be
able to take much more and try to dig in
and defend instead but i think the
question ambassador volker is what
happens about this 20 percent i mean
you're quite right avril d haynes the
director of u.s national intelligence
did say russia controls about 20 of
ukraine but then you have president
zielinski remaining firm on the
assertion that ukraine will regain all
of its sovereignty by retaking all of
this territory is this even realistic
uh it is realistic
it's ambitious but it is realistic uh
the ukrainians now having basically let
the russians exhaust themselves
militarily
and russia not gaining more ground will
now be in a position where they are just
sitting there ukraine will begin counter
offenses to retake territory they will
be more strategic than the russians were
what the russians just took in luhansk
is not very militarily significant the
ukrainians will be first trying to get
the russians out of herson
cutting off their supply lines there and
pushing them back
breaking the land bridge between donbass
and crimea
probably around malitopol
and trying to push the russians further
away from harkief all of this i think is
quite achievable how far the ukrainians
can push back we don't know yet but we
know they have the determination to
fight is this what victory looks like
for ukraine given the situation on the
ground now
well victory for ukraine is its survival
as a sovereign independent european
democracy and that's already assured now
the question is can they get all of
their territory back or not uh i
certainly hope they can but that will be
part of the fighting that we see coming
up later this summer and in the honor a
lot of this will depend on how uh the
negotiations finally uh end up i mean
they're supposed to begin at some point
they will have to begin at some point
and just on that point i'd like to draw
your attention to a recent joint article
in the telegraph that ukrainian foreign
minister dimitra kuleba authored with
his uk
counterpart list trust they wrote and i
quote putin will only be serious about
negotiations once the ukrainian people
have pushed his troops back and i think
we both agree that that won't be quick
or easy
is there a risk that ukraine's western
backers won't have the patience for that
uh there is a risk you know you do hear
periodically statements about uh well we
must not humiliate putin i think it was
president who said that or that ukraine
needs to negotiate the costs are too
high
but every time that happens the
ukrainians insist that it's their
country and they will be the ones to
decide whether they are fighting back to
retake it or not and they have every
intention to do so and as long as the
ukrainians maintain that resolve i am
pretty sure that the west and the united
states will continue to support ukraine
i mean you talked about what president
macron had said for which he was quite
heavily criticized uh by the ukrainian
but then you also have italy which
circulated in may a peace plan which
essentially put the donbass and crimea
up for negotiation between russia and
ukraine do you think there is a real
risk here that richer nations in europe
like germany france italy will push for
a ceasefire even if that comes at the
cost of ukrainian territory
yes yes i think that is a risk uh you
you saw that with the draggy plan you
saw that with macron's comments we've
heard some comments from germany as well
uh and especially as putin will try to
squeeze gas supplies to europe this
winter
he hopes that by creating more pain for
west europeans it will cause governments
in western europe to push ukraine to
give up territory uh i think it's
despicable that that is putin's plan but
that is what he will try to do
and it is important that all of us keep
up the support for ukraine and keep the
pressure back on russia and not not give
in to those calls for ukraine to give up
territory what happens down the line
ambassador volker if during negotiations
ukraine demands things that its western
backers aren't ready to support
well it's hard to know what that would
be because at this point i think the
western countries that are supporting
ukraine
continuously reaffirm that we support
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and ukraine has a right to fight back
and retake territory so there's nothing
that ukraine is asking for or saying
that they have not received support for
as a matter of principle from the west
that is for the time being let's talk
about the west as a whole and i think uh
by virtue of you having been a u.s
ambassador to nato we do need to discuss
the us's role here moving forward now so
far in the united states it appears that
the public is heavily behind whatever
actions the government is taking in
support of ukraine but given the
domestic issues some very divisive
domestic issues that are playing out in
the united states now
how long can this public support stay
the course
well talking about the united states i
think that
it will not only stay the course but it
will increase
the biden administration has been slow
and doing partial steps and getting a
lot of pressure from the congress
republicans and democrats to do more and
do it faster
and that is based on strong public
support for ukraine
so i see midterm elections actually
strengthening the position in congress
to push the administration to be doing
even more to help ukraine just about
those midterm elections they're going to
be happening in november and it's widely
predicted that the republicans will end
up controlling the house and the senate
you are certain that u.s bipartisanship
will remain beyond november
yes i think so we've seen it already
where you have a republican
senator senator joni ernst you have a
republican
senator
on the foreign affairs committee senator
johnson you have others and they are
working very closely with their
democratic counterparts the chair of the
foreign relations committee uh senator
menendez the europe's committee
subcommittee chair senator shaheen
they're all working together they are
pushing for more support for ukraine and
uh you have uh even if it flips and you
now have republicans in the majority and
democrats in the minority i think they
would continue to work together to
provide that support you're giving names
of you're giving names of republicans
let me also throw some republican names
at you senate hopeful jd vance for
instance is saying i quote i got to be
honest with you i don't really care what
happens to ukraine one way or the other
you have senator rand paul who is saying
that the u.s shouldn't be ukraine's
court sugar daddy i mean these are the
voices that you're hearing on the
republican side of things could these
voices not affect the mood in the
republican party going forward
especially after november
well they are not the leading voices
right now and i don't believe they will
be after november either and rand paul
has been in the senate for years and he
has usually expressed opinions like that
and usually been quite alone
there are in addition to the two that
you mentioned uh if jd vance is elected
that'll add a voice uh there's usu
there's one or two others who are often
skeptical uh about continued u.s support
or the scale of u.s support but you have
senator mitch mcconnell as the minority
leader if he becomes the majority leader
again he has offered very strong support
for ukraine and the vast majority of the
republican senators
and i can name dozens of them are very
strongly supportive of ukraine in fact
very critical of the administration for
not doing more i mean you talk about
what was going to happen in november but
already in may we saw some opposition
within the republican party especially
when it came to passing the 40 billion
dollar package of assistance for ukraine
you had 11 republicans in the senate 57
in the house who voted against it you
are certain that this does not reflect
cracks in the republican party over
support for ukraine
uh no there are fringes on the right and
there are fringes on the left uh who do
not want to see the us supporting
ukraine for whatever reasons whether
it's budgetary or
fear of russia or whatever it might be
but you also have take that number 11.
as 11 republicans you have a handful of
democrats as well let's push it up to
20. that means there are still 80
senators republican and democrat
prepared to vote for just about anything
to support russia or to impose sanctions
on russia i'm sorry support ukraine or
put sanctions on russia so that strong
bipartisan support from the heart of
both parties will remain there is
opposition within the democratic party
as well it's not just the republicans i
mean representative roe khanna for
example he has said prolonged
never-ending conflict is wreaking havoc
on the american economy and the global
economy and people don't want to see a
resigned attitude that this is just
going to go along go not go on as long
as it's going to go on
surely president biden can't ignore this
moving forward
uh well that's what i just said is that
even if you take the fringes on both
sides and put them together
you're still not going to get more than
20 votes in the senate
so that is a very solid majority to work
with and there are strong voices on the
democratic side including senator
menendez the chair of the senate foreign
relations committee chuck schumer is
currently the majority leader the head
of the house foreign affairs committee
gregory meeks all very supportive of the
administration president biden and very
supportive of the
positions that the administration has
taken to to provide aid to ukraine
ambassador walker you served under
donald trump i suppose the worry here in
europe is if
his isolationist brand of u.s foreign
policy could make a return
to the white house in 2024 is that a
real concern
uh yes people should be concerned about
that uh you know we've had
and i would take it beyond president
trump we've had every u.s president
after their election talks in one way or
another about pulling back from our
commitments abroad and focusing on
nation-building at home as president
obama said or it's the economy stupid as
president clinton said
or not fighting other people's civil
wars and ending two wars as president
obama said uh so this america first
policy of president trump all you know
is part of that tradition it's a little
bit more um you know
outspoken in the way president trump
does it but it is a tradition that's
there that we do have to watch out for
fortunately i think russia's aggression
that we saw since february has
strengthened the internationalist side
of both the republican and democratic
parties and it has caused them just to
recognize russia's threat and the need
to push back against it right let's look
at the other side of western unity
what's happening here in the european
union sweden's foreign minister anna
linde has warned that interest in the
ukraine war is fading because food
prices energy prices are rising they are
expected to rise even further heading
later into the year
boris johnson is warning of ukraine
fatigue can europe sustain support for
the long term for ukraine
yeah that's the challenge i think and
here i as we talked about already i
think it will get harder for europe as
russia squeezes
energy this winter
both in terms of price and availability
it's going to cause some real hardship
in europe and that in turn may put
pressure on governments to say hey it's
time for ukraine to negotiate a
ceasefire i think that that
is the greater risk that we face right
now essentially what you're saying is
russian gas could derail european unity
uh it has done so in the past and it
could be could do so again it is
certainly uh vladimir putin's intention
to use energy that way so when jens when
uh nato chief jens stoltenberg says
ukraine will have support from the bloc
quote for as long as it takes
do you believe him
well i do i think he's making the right
statements i think it is the intention
of every country now but just as you're
identifying some of these trends that
are at work you can imagine it could
change and that's what we all have to
work against to make sure that uh both
in the united states and especially in
europe especially in the winter if
there's an energy crunch that we have
the fortitude to support ukraine
remember the ukrainians are paying for
our security with their lives
we would be paying for their security
with higher prices you also said in
march ambassador that the key to
ukraine's survival is holding off
russian forces long enough for sanctions
against russia to have their impact do
you think sanctions have gone far enough
no i don't i think that they need more
time and that is something where you
know week by week we see some evidence
that uh you know sanctions are taking a
bite for instance uh the shareholders of
gas bomb just voted to increase the
amount of taxes that they're paying to
the russian government that's an
indicator that the russian government is
short on cash uh so there are things
that we're starting to see but i think
we need to close loopholes in the
sanctions particularly against smaller
russian banks that are funding for the
bigger banks uh financial transfers to
russia that are still getting through
and uh shipment of oil from russia let's
take away the insurance of those ships
and imports of russian oil and gas which
are still not shut down yet given the
state of the european union the way it
is right now do you see that happening
at all oil is certainly possible there's
no reason why imports of russian oil
could not be stopped gas i know it's
harder i know people see a tough
transition especially going through this
winter but
again ukrainians are paying for this
with their lives we have to have a sense
of urgency even if it means a bit higher
prices and i think europe has the means
to actually be able to take off take
itself off of russian gas sooner than
the end of next year which is the
current idea and let's look ahead to
possible future ties between the eu and
russia in an interview on the 27th of
june ambassador you said the following
the decision the europeans really need
to be making is we can't live with this
genocidal maniac next door to us anymore
i think you and i both agree that putin
doesn't look to be going away anytime
soon so what does that future look like
well again you can't deal with someone
like putin
he has ordered his forces into ukraine
as a direct war of aggression he's lied
to all of us about his intentions
repeatedly he has
directed his forces to commit war crimes
including use of rape as a weapon of war
including the killing of uh civilians
including the targeting of maternity
hospitals and civilian facilities uh so
this is not something where anyone in
europe can work with this putin this
regime that so the regime is going to
have to go
now that being said i i don't agree that
we won't be seeing the end of putin
anytime soon
there are many indications that he is in
poor health and that may be even be one
of the reasons why he is driving so hard
to to steal these territories from
ukraine now he wants it to be part of
his personal legacy so i think that
pressures are building uh as a result of
the war effort and and not going well
for russia as a result of sanctions as a
result of internal pressures in russia
that something may snap and we should
just not be uh
we should not be afraid of that we
should keep pressing uh putting the
pressure on russia ambassador walker
what would you like to see happening now
in europe so that uh peace returns after
this war
well i'd like to see russia withdraw its
forces from ukraine that's the way we'll
have peace again
if russia is able to continue to attack
its neighbors to steal their territory
to commit war crimes and get away with
it there will never be security in
europe and there won't actually be peace
and remember that russia occupies parts
of moldova and georgia as well so this
what we're seeing in ukraine is brutal
but is a continuation of a many years
pattern and that means that pattern will
continue in the future unless russia is
forced to pull out now
ambassador kurt volker we'll leave it
there thank you so much for joining us
thank you very much
[Music]
you